Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. My dear mum and dad, it don't seem possible we're out on the briny writing to you. Well dears, so far we're having a delightful trip. The weather is beautiful and the ship magnificent. We can't describe the tables, it's like a floating town. I can tell you we do swank, We shall miss it on the trains. We go third on them. You would not imagine you were on a ship. There's hardly any motion. She's so large
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我亲爱的爸爸妈妈，我们竟然真的在海上给你们写信，这简直不可思议。亲爱的，到目前为止，我们的旅程非常愉快。天气很好，船也很壮观。我们无法形容这里的餐桌，它就像一座漂浮的城镇。我可以告诉你们，我们过得很奢华，在火车上我们可享受不到这些，我们坐的是三等座。你们绝对想象不到自己是在船上，几乎感觉不到晃动，它太大了。
we've not felt sick. Yet we expect to get to Queenstown today. So I thought I'd drop this with the mails. We had a fine send off from Southampton. Lots of love. Don't worry about us. Ever your loving children. Harvey, Lot and Madge. So that, Tom, is a letter from a chap called Harvey Collier to his parents from the Titanic. And Harvey was a grocer from a place called Bishopstoke in Hampshire. And he was also a big bell ringer in the local church. And he and his family were emigrating to Idaho. When they left, because Harvey was big in the local church,
我们还没感到晕船。不过我们预计今天能到达皇后镇，所以我打算把这封信随邮包寄出。我们在南安普顿出发时场面很壮观。送上满满的爱。别担心我们。永远爱你们的孩子，哈维、洛特和玛奇。那么，汤姆，这就是一位叫哈维·科利尔的人从泰坦尼克号上写给他父母的信。哈维是汉普郡毕晓普斯托克地方的一名杂货商，他还是当地教堂的一名资深敲钟人。他和他的家人正准备移民到爱达荷州。当他们离开时，因为哈维在当地教堂很有地位，
there was a great send-off for them. They sort of sat them down in the churchyard, and people went up to the tower and rang the bells for them. It was very moving. Harvey loved it. His wife, Charlotte, was sitting there and she was a bit ambivalent about going to America. So she was a little bit tearful or something. They had all their savings with them, which he had in banknotes and the lining of his
大家为他们举行了隆重的欢送仪式。他们把他们请到教堂墓地坐下，人们走到塔楼上为他们敲响了钟声。那场面非常感人。哈维很喜欢。他的妻子夏洛特坐在那里，对去美国这件事感到有些矛盾，所以她有点泪眼婆娑之类的。他们带上了所有的积蓄，他把钱换成了钞票，缝在
jacket. And I don't think it's giving anything away to say that the fate of the Collier family is very poignant. And those are the human details, aren't away to say that the fate of the Collier family is very poignant. And those are the human details, aren't they, that make the story of the Titanic just so incredibly resonant. It is. And the idea of writing back to your loved one saying, don't worry about us. Everything's great. It's all going to be fine. And of course, the reason that we're doing this episode, the reason that the Titanic has the kind of the mythic resonance that it does is the contrast between the confidence and the horror that we know is coming. So before we get to the horror, we're going to look at some of the details of the people who were traveling. And everyone will know that there are lots of millionaires on it, but they will also know, particularly if they've seen Titanic, the film, that there are lots of
夹克的衬里里。我想说科利尔一家的命运非常令人唏嘘，这不算剧透。正是这些人性化的细节，让泰坦尼克号的故事如此令人感同身受，不是吗？确实。写信给亲人说“别担心我们，一切都很好，一切都会好起来的”，这种想法……当然，我们制作这一集的原因，以及泰坦尼克号之所以具有这种神话般的共鸣，是因为我们所知的即将到来的恐怖与当时那种自信之间的反差。所以在我们谈到恐怖之前，我们要看看一些乘客的细节。大家都知道船上有许多百万富翁，但他们也会知道，特别是如果看过电影《泰坦尼克号》的话，船上还有很多
people in steerage. And in the last episode, I quoted Francis Wilson making the comment that basically the Titanic is a ship that only seems to be a luxury hotel, but actually it's there to carry poor emigrants. So in these next two episodes, we're going to look at the range of people who are traveling on the Titanic. And as anyone who has seen the James Cameron film will know, there are of course millionaires, and then there are people down in steerage. And we're going to look at both groups of people. And Dominic, we're also going to look at the people who are traveling in second class yes who don't make it into the film and who slightly tend to be written out because we do enjoy the kind of downtown abbey idea of upstairs and
三等舱的乘客。在上一集中，我引用了弗朗西斯·威尔逊的评论，他说泰坦尼克号本质上只是一艘看起来像豪华酒店的船，但实际上它是为了运送贫穷的移民。所以在接下来的两集里，我们将看看泰坦尼克号上形形色色的乘客。正如看过詹姆斯·卡梅隆电影的人所知，船上当然有百万富翁，也有住在三等舱的人。我们将审视这两类人。多米尼克，我们还要看看那些住在二等舱的人，是的，他们没有出现在电影里，而且往往被忽略了，因为我们确实很喜欢那种《唐顿庄园》式的楼上和
downstairs don't we and the fact that actually there are lots of people kind of in the middle is often written out of the story it is because I think people want to turn it into a parable, don't they? A morality tale about inequality and hubris. Yeah. And so you have, you know, John Jacob Astor, and then you have some very poor guy played by Leonardo DiCaprio or something. Absolutely. But actually we miss in that the complexity of, you know, all these people who were there, many of whom were, as you say,
楼下的概念，不是吗？事实上，有很多处于中间阶层的人往往被排除在故事之外。确实如此，因为我认为人们想把它变成一个寓言，不是吗？一个关于不平等和傲慢的道德故事。是的。所以你有约翰·雅各布·阿斯特，然后你有一个由莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥扮演的穷小子之类的角色。绝对是这样。但实际上，我们忽略了所有这些人的复杂性，他们中的许多人正如你所说，
in the middle and make the story much more complicated. Right. So having said that, should we kick off with the millionaires? Yeah, why not? You know, we're very much a class-based podcast. We are. So let's go in with the millionaires first. So in the last episode, we talked about how the Titanic was a product of the Gilded Age, of the capitalism of the Gilded Age, of the competition between different companies,
处于中间阶层，这让故事变得复杂得多。好吧，既然如此，我们要不要从百万富翁开始讲起？好啊，为什么不呢？你知道，我们是一个非常注重阶级的播客。我们确实是。所以让我们先从百万富翁开始。在上一集中，我们谈到了泰坦尼克号是如何成为镀金时代的产物，镀金时代资本主义的产物，以及不同公司之间竞争的产物，
British, German, for control of the Atlantic trade we talked about, Belfast, didn't we? And we had the Titanic going through all its tests and then being brought to Southampton and then, of course, sailing out of Southampton Harbour. And you were very rude, if I remember, about Captain Smith, weren't you? Yes, I was. You were accused of incompetence, I think very harshly. Not incompetence, but perhaps not being as fully on the ball as once he was. Well, Dominic, I think the evidence is tough.
英国和德国为了争夺大西洋贸易的控制权。我们谈到了贝尔法斯特，不是吗？泰坦尼克号完成了所有的测试，然后被带到南安普顿，当然，最后从南安普顿港启航。如果我没记错的话，你对史密斯船长的评价非常刻薄，对吧？是的，我是。我想你指责他无能，这太严厉了。不是无能，也许只是不像以前那样全神贯注了。好吧，多米尼克，我认为证据很确凿。
Anyone can have a mistake. Anyone can have a mistake in a transatlantic crossing. Come on. He has four mistakes in the space of a year. But anyway, let's not get onto that. He did a lot of very successful voyages. And I think it's harsh to judge him on the... On his last year.
任何人都会犯错。在横跨大西洋的航行中，任何人都会犯错。得了吧。他在一年之内犯了四个错误。但无论如何，我们别谈这个了。他完成了很多非常成功的航行。我认为仅凭他最后一年来评判他太严厉了。
On one, yeah. So actually, most of the passengers that morning start off in London, and they come from Waterloo. Now, we talked last time about how Southampton had been built up as this great rival to Liverpool, and it's been built up by the Liverpool and Southwestern Railway, among other companies. So at about 7.30, there is a train that will leave Waterloo. It's the boat train, and it will head to Southampton. And there are hundreds of people on this train. And actually, there are paparazzi at Waterloo, aren't there?
仅凭一次，是的。所以实际上，那天早上大多数乘客都是从伦敦出发的，他们来自滑铁卢车站。我们上次谈到南安普顿是如何被打造为利物浦的强大竞争对手的，它是由利物浦和西南铁路公司以及其他公司共同建立的。所以大约在7点30分，有一列火车将离开滑铁卢。那是邮轮专列，它将前往南安普顿。火车上有数百人。而且滑铁卢车站还有狗仔队，不是吗？
Yeah, so that's brilliant, isn't it? Camera fiends, they're called. Yes. I love that phrase. So there are camera fiends there because, as you say, there are so many millionaires. So the train goes off. Waterloo is being redeveloped. So it's kind of very chaotic and messy and sooty and all that sort of stuff.
是的，这太精彩了，不是吗？他们被称为“相机狂人”。是的。我喜欢这个词。所以那里有相机狂人，因为正如你所说，有太多的百万富翁了。火车出发了。滑铁卢车站正在重建，所以那里非常混乱、肮脏，到处都是煤烟之类的东西。
They head down to Southampton. And at Southampton, 427 passengers in first and second class get on and 495 in third class. And then they pick up more passengers, actually a lot more first class passengers at Cherbourg because they go straight to Cherbourg. And here, clearly, they're picking up Americans, for example, who have been traveling in the continent, who have been in Paris and so on and so forth. And we talked, didn't we, how they have to go out in kind of little boats to take them out because Titanic is so huge, it can't actually get into Cherbourg. And so they finally pull out of Cherbourg at eight o'clock that evening and
他们前往南安普顿。在南安普顿，427名头等舱和二等舱乘客登船，495名三等舱乘客登船。然后他们接载了更多乘客，实际上在瑟堡接载了更多头等舱乘客，因为他们直接去了瑟堡。在这里，他们显然接载了美国人，例如，那些一直在欧洲大陆旅行，去过巴黎等等的人。我们谈到过，他们必须乘坐小船去接他们，因为泰坦尼克号太大了，无法进入瑟堡。所以他们最终在当天晚上八点离开瑟堡，
they are heading for Queenstown, now Cove, in Ireland. So of those first class passengers, there are 337 of them, I think. I mean, the interesting thing is that there are always different estimates for the numbers. Each book gives you a slightly different figure because we're never entirely sure who turned up and who didn't, which we'll come to in a second. But it's definite that it's not filter capacity, is it? By some estimates, under 50%. Now that is really interesting. And there's a couple of things in that. One of them is that the competition for the transatlantic crossing is so fierce that there was actually a massive overcapacity. So there are more births than there are potential
他们正前往爱尔兰的皇后镇，也就是现在的科夫。在那些头等舱乘客中，我想有337人。我的意思是，有趣的是，对人数的估计总是各不相同。每本书给出的数字都略有不同，因为我们永远无法完全确定谁来了，谁没来，我们稍后会谈到这一点。但可以肯定的是，它没有满载，对吧？据估计，不到50%。这真的很有趣。其中有几点原因。其中之一是横跨大西洋的竞争非常激烈，以至于实际上存在巨大的运力过剩。所以铺位比潜在的
first-class passengers yeah but the other thing richard davenport hines has a really good section on this i think he says you know it was a great trait of edwardian millionaires it was seen as a sort of badge of their quality that they would change their plans and cancel things and put everybody out yeah at the last minute that was a sign of your status. People were always cancelling things in a way that now I think, well, maybe tech billionaires cancel things. I don't know. I feel bad about cancelling. I mean, I wouldn't book a transatlantic crossing and then just not turn up. I mean, that's the expression of your middle-class bourgeois uptightness. It is. Yes, it is, Tom. Whereas if you're a high-spending,
头等舱乘客要多。是的，但另一件事是，理查德·达文波特-海恩斯对此有一段非常好的论述，我想他说，你知道，这是爱德华时代百万富翁的一个伟大特征，他们会改变计划、取消行程并让所有人扫兴，这被视为他们身份的一种标志。是的，在最后一刻。人们总是取消行程，以至于现在我想，也许科技亿万富翁会取消行程。我不知道。我觉得取消行程很不好意思。我的意思是，我不会预订横跨大西洋的航行然后就不去了。我的意思是，那是你中产阶级资产阶级拘谨的表现。确实是。是的，确实是，汤姆。而如果你是一个高消费的、
gilded-age billionaire, there's nothing you'd enjoy more than letting people down. No. I need to be less polite to waiters and things like that. So several millionaires could have been on this maiden voyage of the Titanic. So there's Milton Hershey.
镀金时代的亿万富翁，没有什么比让别人失望更让你享受的了。不。我需要对服务员之类的人更不礼貌一些。所以几位百万富翁本可以参加泰坦尼克号的处女航。比如米尔顿·赫尔希。
The chocolate. Chocolate millionaire. The chocolate guy. Yeah. To be honest, I mean, he deserved to go down. That's terrible chocolate, isn't it? Hershey's. Yeah, terrible. Terrible chocolate. There's Henry Clay Frick. Yeah. To be honest, I mean, he deserved to go down. That's terrible chocolate, isn't it, Hershey's? Yeah, terrible.
巧克力。巧克力百万富翁。那个做巧克力的人。是的。老实说，我认为他活该沉没。那是很糟糕的巧克力，不是吗？好时巧克力。是的，糟糕。糟糕的巧克力。还有亨利·克莱·弗里克。是的。老实说，我认为他活该沉没。那是很糟糕的巧克力，不是吗，好时巧克力？是的，糟糕。
Terrible chocolate. There's Henry Clay Frick, as in the Frick, the art gallery. George Vanderbilt, another very kind of gilded age American millionaire name. He doesn't go. But of course, the famous person who doesn't go is the guy who's behind the whole shebang, who is Pierpoint Morgan. And so he takes over Frick's booking, but then he cancels because he is keen to oversee the movement of his art collection from Paris to America. Or that is what he says, because this
糟糕的巧克力。还有亨利·克莱·弗里克，就是弗里克艺术博物馆的那个弗里克。乔治·范德比尔特，另一个非常典型的镀金时代美国百万富翁的名字。他没去。但当然，那个没去的大人物是整个计划的幕后推手，也就是皮尔庞特·摩根。他接手了弗里克的预订，但后来取消了，因为他急于监督他的艺术收藏品从巴黎运往美国。或者这就是他所说的，因为这
is the focus for some hot conspiracy theories. Are you up to speed with them? I know they exist. I consider them demented, so I haven't really gone into them as much as I should. So the conspiracy theory is that, we talked about how Morgan is basically behind the setting up of the American Central Bank, isn't he? That he kind of comes to the rescue. Yeah. Well, he- He's America's banker. Yeah.
是某些热门阴谋论的焦点。你了解这些吗？我知道它们存在。我认为它们很疯狂，所以我没有像我应该做的那样深入研究它们。所以阴谋论是，我们谈到摩根基本上是美国中央银行成立的幕后推手，不是吗？他算是挺身而出。是的。嗯，他——他是美国的银行家。是的。
And the conspiracy theory is that John Jacob Astor, Benjamin Guggenheim, and Isidore Strauss, all of whom are absolute top league millionaires, are against this. And so Morgan has arranged for them to go on the Titanic so that they can be removed, taken out of the equation. Which I agree, doesn't seem an entirely... It seems a roundabout and expensive way of getting rid of them. An unreliable way. What if they get into the lifeboats? Exactly. But I just mentioned that.
阴谋论是，约翰·雅各布·阿斯特、本杰明·古根海姆和伊西多尔·斯特劳斯，他们都是绝对顶级的百万富翁，他们反对这一点。所以摩根安排他们登上泰坦尼克号，这样他们就可以被清除，从等式中剔除。我同意，这看起来并不完全……这似乎是一种迂回且昂贵的摆脱他们的方法。一种不可靠的方法。如果他们上了救生艇怎么办？正是如此。但我只是提到了这一点。
I just put that out there because we don't want people listening to think that we're not acknowledging the conspiracy theories because you particularly had quite a lot of grief for your scepticism
我只是把它摆出来，因为我们不想让听众认为我们没有承认这些阴谋论，因为你特别因为你对肯尼迪阴谋论的怀疑而受到了很多指责。
towards JFK conspiracy theories. That's true. I'm actually just part of the conspiracy, to be quite frank. I can admit that now. Okay. So,
那是真的。坦率地说，我其实就是阴谋的一部分。我现在可以承认这一点了。好的。那么，
Aster is by Father Richard, isn't he? He is. Colonel Jack admit that now. Okay. So Aster is by far the richest, isn't he? He is. Colonel Jack, he's called. John Jacob Aster IV. The Asters are the sort of paradigmatic, dominant family, dynasty of Gilded Age New York. He owns a lot of New York, among other things. It's not just a hotelier. He's a slum landlord. But the hotels are interesting, aren't they? Because they kind of provide the model for the luxury and first class that the Titanic embodies. Absolutely, they do. So the most famous one, of course, is the Waldorf Astoria.
阿斯特是理查德的父亲，不是吗？他是。杰克上校，他被称为约翰·雅各布·阿斯特四世。阿斯特家族是镀金时代纽约的典型、主导家族、王朝。他拥有纽约的很多东西，除其他事项外。他不仅仅是一位酒店经营者。他还是个贫民窟房东。但这些酒店很有趣，不是吗？因为它们为泰坦尼克号所体现的奢华和头等舱提供了模式。绝对是这样。所以最著名的一个当然是华尔道夫酒店。
It has Aster in the name. And the Waldorf Astoria was seen as having set standards in hotels. So it's the Waldorf Astoria really that invents the idea of you going to a sort of downtown city centre hotel and there being a tea room, a bar, a lounge, a sort of gentleman's club atmosphere. Yeah. So in other words, it's not just a place you sleep. It's a place where, you know, all life is there. A range of entertainments are on tap. Exactly. Exactly. place where you know all life is there a range of entertainments are on tap exactly exactly but also the fact that he is this notorious slum landlord while enjoying all this luxury in the luxury
它的名字里有阿斯特。华尔道夫酒店被视为设定了酒店的标准。所以真正发明了那种去市中心酒店，那里有茶室、酒吧、休息室、绅士俱乐部氛围的想法的，确实是华尔道夫酒店。是的。所以换句话说，它不仅仅是你睡觉的地方。它是一个你所知道的所有生活都在那里，各种娱乐设施应有尽有的地方。正是如此。正是如此。但同时，他是一个臭名昭著的贫民窟房东，却在豪华酒店里享受着这一切奢华，我认为这也是在公众想象中叠加在泰坦尼克号上的东西。是的，我想是这样。他们一边在头等舱里啜饮鸡尾酒和香槟，而三等舱里全是老鼠和污水。我的意思是，我们会谈到这一点，看看这是否准确。是的。而且他看起来，正如那个时代的美国百万富翁一样，他们试图表现得比英国人更像英国人。所以他，你知道，他穿着带有天鹅绒领子的大衣。
hotels and things i think that that is also something that gets superimposed in the public imagination on the titanic yeah i think so the idea of them sipping cocktails and champagne and things in first class while down in steerage it's all rats and bilge water. I mean, we will come to that and see whether that is accurate or not. Yeah. And he looks, as American millionaires of that era did, they try to be kind of more English than the English. So he's sort of, you know, he wears an overcoat with a velvet collar.
那其实有点像奈杰尔·法拉奇，不是吗？他戴着圆顶礼帽，拿着雨伞，留着漂亮的胡子，所有这些东西，他看起来就像《欢乐满人间》里的父亲。是的，他确实是，班克斯先生。但有趣的是，他有一个年轻的新娘，不是吗？他有。马德琳·福斯，确实是。马德琳·福斯，这有点像1970年代摇滚明星的行为。所以她当时18岁，这非常有争议，因为她比他小几十岁。他们在第五大道举行了盛大的招待会，他要在那里把她介绍给他所有的朋友和所有其他社会名流，结果很多人没来。所以当他们去歌剧院之类的地方时，很多人会无视他们。他们去了法国和埃及，她
That's actually a bit Nigel Farage, isn't it? He wears a bowler hat and he has an umbrella and he's got this nice moustache and all that sort of thing he looks like the father in mary poppins yes he does mr banks but interestingly he has a child bride doesn't he he does madeline force as was yes madeline force which is slightly more sort of 1970s rock star behavior so she was 18 and this was very controversial because she's decades his junior they had a big reception at fifth avenue where he's going to introduce her to all his sort of friends and all the other society people and lots of people didn't turn up so lots of people would ignore them when they went to the opera and things they have gone off to france and egypt she is
怀孕了，怀孕四个月。他们现在正要回纽约，他们有庞大的随从。他有一个男仆。她有一个女仆。她有一个保姆。他们还有一只叫基蒂的狗。我知道你非常喜欢狗。是的。
pregnant four months pregnant. And they are now coming back to New York and they have this big retinue. They have a valet. She has a maid. She has a nursemaid. And they have a dog called Kitty. I know you're very keen on the dogs. Yes.
所以这是一只万能梗，多米尼克，泰坦尼克号上确认的12只狗之一。确认的狗。是的。所以可能还有其他狗，我们不知道，它们被偷运上船了。所以有几只万能梗。有一只查理王小猎犬，有一只猎狐犬，有一只斗牛犬，还有一只大丹犬。大丹犬？谁会带一只大丹犬上船？嗯，所以那只大丹犬没能上救生艇。
So in Airedale, one of 12 confirmed dogs, Dominic, who were on the Titanic. Confirmed dogs. Yes. So there might have been other dogs, we don't know, whoic, who were on the Titanic. Confirmed dogs? Yes. So there might have been other dogs, we don't know, who kind of got smuggled aboard. So there were several Airedales. There was a King Charles Spaniel, there was a Fox Terrier, there was a Bulldog, and there was a Great Dane. Great Dane? Who takes a Great Dane on a ship? Well, so the Great Dane does not get into the lifeboat.
对。恐怕基蒂也没能上。所以基蒂淹死了。对。但有三只狗最终上了救生艇。有两只博美犬。其中一只叫“女士”，它是被裹在毯子里偷运上船的。然后还有一只叫“孙中山”的北京犬。哇。
Right. And nor, I'm afraid, does Kitty. So Kitty drowns. Right. But there are three that do get onto the boats in due course. There are two Pomeranians. One of those is called Lady, and she gets smuggled on, wrapped in a blanket. And then there's a Pekingese called Sun Yat-sen. Wow.
它也成功登船了。所以孙中山是中国领导人。是的。所以听过我们“顶级狗”那一集的听众，记得有一只叫卢蒂的北京犬。所以很明显，北京犬被起了不太政治正确的名字。这非常维多利亚和爱德华时代。所以孙中山也逃过一劫。还有船上的猫，珍妮，很遗憾它没能活下来。
Who also makes it on. So Sun Yat-sen is the Chinese leader. Yeah. So people who listen to our Top Dogs episode, there was Luti the Pekingese. So clearly Pekingese are given not entirely politically correct names. This is very much a Victorian and Edwardian thing. So Sun Yat-sen gets away as well. And there's also the ship's cat, Jenny, who sadly doesn't make it.
珍妮没活下来？没有。哦，真难过。所以船上既有动物，也有百万富翁等等。但回到人类身上，汤姆。是的，回到人类的故事，是的。所以其他百万富翁，有一个人，你已经提到过他了，本·古根海姆。
Jenny doesn't make it? No. Oh, sad. So there are animals as well as millionaires and so on. But back to the humans for a second, Tom. Yes, back to the human story, yes. So other millionaires, there's a chap called, you mentioned him already, Ben Guggenheim.
所以古根海姆家族，同样是一个艺术画廊的名字，古根海姆画廊等等。古根海姆家族在科罗拉多州的莱德维尔银矿发了财。他们是臭名昭著的工贼，非常强硬的商业大亨。本·古根海姆，我认为通常被认为是他们中最有吸引力的一位。
So the Guggenheim family, again, an art gallery name, the Guggenheim Gallery and so on. The Guggenheims had made their money out in Colorado in the silver mines in Leadville. They are notorious kind of stripe breakers, very hard-nosed sort of business tycoons. Ben Guggenheim, I think, is generally thought the sort of most attractive of them.
他实际上已经离开了家族企业。他住在第五大道。他看待自己，就像许多人所做的那样，他有点像亨利·詹姆斯小说中的人物之类的。他们都是这样，不是吗？是的，他们是。他们去欧洲，在威尼斯和巴黎闲逛。他有一个情人，不是吗？
He's actually left the family business. He lives on Fifth Avenue. He sees himself, as so many people did, he's a bit like a character in a Henry James novel or something. They all are, aren't they? Yeah, they are. They go off to Europe and they hang around in Venice and Paris. He's got a lover, hasn't he?
他娶了一个只有18岁的新娘。全是那种事情。确实是。那是吉莲·安德森还是谁加入了我们？是的，我们不会收到那个。所以本·古根海姆在巴黎有一个情妇，叫莱昂汀·奥巴尔，她是一位歌手。她和他一起旅行，同样，他有一个庞大的随从，她有一个女仆，他有一个男仆，他们有一个叫勒内·佩诺的司机，他有一个终极的法国名字。所以他在二等舱，不是吗？
He has married a bride who is only 18 years old. It's all that kind of thing. It is. Was that Gillian Anderson or somebody there joining us joining us yeah we will not be receiving that uh so ben guggenheim has a mistress in paris called leontine obar who is a singer she's traveling with him again he's got a big entourage she's got a maid he's got a valet uh they have a chauffeur called renee renee pernaud he's got the ultimate French name. So he's down in second class, isn't he?
是的。所以他们都在那里。而且可能因为他和情妇在一起，他们可能保持低调，不与人交往。我们不知道，但有种感觉，他们不会和其他百万富翁走得太近，因为如果他们知道他和他的法国情妇在一起，他们会感到震惊。然后是怀德纳家族。所以我们在第一集提到过他们，不是吗？
Yes. So they're all there. And again, probably because he's with his mistress, they probably keep themselves to themselves and don't mix. We don't know, but there are senses that they would not have mixed that closely with the other millionaires because they would have been horrified at the thought of him with his French mistress. Then there's the Wideners. So we mentioned them, didn't we, in the first episode? because they would have been horrified at the thought of him with his French mistress.
所以这一切的祖父，家长式人物，彼得·怀德纳，他与摩根联手建立了美国钢铁公司以及各种各样的东西。是的。他的儿子和孙子都在泰坦尼克号上。是的。所以乔治和埃莉诺是他的儿子和儿媳。他们去巴黎是为了给女儿的婚礼购买东西，也就是嫁妆。
Then there's the Wideners. So we mentioned them, didn't we, in the first episode. So the grandfather of it all, the patriarchal figure, Peter Widener, he joined with Morgan in setting up American Steel and all kinds of things like that. Yeah. And his son and his grandson are on the Titanic. Yes. So George and Eleanor are his son and daughter-in-law. And they have gone to Paris to buy the stuff, the trousseau, for their daughter's wedding.
他们带着儿子一起去了。他们的儿子是哈里。我认为哈里是一个非常有吸引力的人。是的，他是。因为他是一位伟大的藏书家。是的。所以他20多岁，不是吗？自从他第一次去哈佛以来，他就成了初版书的瘾君子。所以他有很多狄更斯的初版书，本·琼森的。
And they've taken their son with them. Their son is Harry. He's a very attractive person, I think, Harry. Yeah, he is. Because he's a great bibliophile. Yes. So he's in his mid-20s, isn't he? And since he first went to Harvard, he has become an addict of first editions. So he's got loads of Dickens first editions, Ben Johnson.
是的。他还有一本莎士比亚的第一对开本。是的。非常令人印象深刻。他在船上随身携带了一本1598年版的弗朗西斯·培根的散文集。是的。他花了260英镑买的。是的。他花了260英镑买的。是的。他母亲的珍珠项链投保了15万
Yeah. And he's got a Shakespeare first folio. Yes. Very impressive. And with him on the ship, he's carrying a 1598 edition of Francis Bacon's essays. Yeah. Which he'd bought for 260 pounds. Yeah. essays yeah which he'd bought for 260 pounds yeah uh his mother's pearls were insured for 150 000
英镑。所以这让你对那个时代的价值有了一些概念，你需要加上多个零才能换算成现代的等值货币。是的，但看过电影《泰坦尼克号》的人会记得，凯特·温斯莱特饰演的角色露丝在她的船舱里有毕加索的《阿维尼翁的少女》。我想她还有一幅德加的作品。我想她还有一幅莫奈的作品，所有这些显然都没有沉没，但在电影里确实沉没了，人们总是对此嗤之以鼻。但这确实反映了一个事实，当然，所有这些珍宝，你知道，现在在美国艺术画廊里的欧洲艺术品，它们中的大多数都是用像泰坦尼克号这样的船只运输的。它们确实是。它们是怎么到那里的？是的，正是如此。而且这些人正是
pounds so that gives you yeah some sense you're going to be adding multiple notes to that to make the modern equivalent yeah but people who've seen titanic the film will remember that uh rose the character played by kate winslet in her cabin She has the Demoiselles d'Avignon by Picasso. I think she has a Degas. I think she has a Monet, all of which obviously didn't sync, but in the film do sync and people always kind of laugh about that. But it does reflect the fact that, of course, all these treasures, you know,pieces of european art that are now in american art galleries most of them were transported on ships like the titanic they were yeah how did they get there yeah exactly exactly and that these are precisely the people who are
运输它们的人。是的，你知道，这就是他们所做的。这与亨利·詹姆斯笔下的人物相比，这绝对是那个世界，他们会把培根的对开本塞进口袋里，是的，因为我想哈佛有一个图书馆，不是吗？怀德纳纪念图书馆，是在他去世后由他的家人建立的。所以是的，我的意思是，显然他们没有带《阿维尼翁的少女》，因为它仍然存在，但嗯，是的，我想在海底确实有艺术杰作。一定有。一定有。所以有金融，有铁路，铁路也有代表。有两组与铁路
transporting them yeah you know this is what they do this is compared to the sort of the henry james characters this is absolutely that world that they will have you know folios of bacon stuffed into their pockets and yeah because I think I think there's a library at Harvard isn't the Widener Memorial Library which was set up right after his death by his his family so yes I mean obviously they didn't take that was a davenior because it still exists but um yeah there are masterpieces of art I I guess, down there on the ocean bed. There must be. There must be. So there's finance, there's railroads, the railroads are represented. There are two family parties that are related to railroad
大亨有关的家庭聚会。有塞耶家族。他们是宾夕法尼亚铁路公司的所有者，这是美国在交通和收入方面最大的铁路公司。海耶斯家族，他们是加拿大国家铁路公司。多米尼克，有同性恋伴侣吗？是的，有一对同性恋伴侣。这是政治界。他们是一对非凡的组合。有一个叫弗朗西斯的人，我会叫他弗朗西斯·米勒，
tycoons. There's the Thayer family. They're the owners of the Pennsylvania Railroad, which is the biggest in terms of traffic and revenue in the United States. The Hayes family, so they are the Grand Trunk Railway of Canada. And Dominic, are there any gay couples? Yes, there is a gay couple. And this is the world of politics. And they're an extraordinary pair. So there's a guy called Francis, I would call him Francis Millet,
但我猜美国人会叫他米勒。他们会叫他弗朗西斯·米勒。他是一位画家。他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。他曾在内战中服役于联邦军队。当俄国人在19世纪70年代与奥斯曼帝国作战时，他曾是俄国的战地记者。他非常擅长素描，那些波士顿公共建筑的精美素描。他是美国罗马学院的院长，这个叫弗朗西斯·米勒的人。他和华盛顿的一个男人住在一起，一个年轻得多的男人。阿奇·巴特。阿奇·巴特，正是如此，他是塔夫脱总统的军事顾问。
but I guess Americans would call him Millet. They'd call him Francis Millet. He's a painter. He's a very impressive man. He'd served with the Union troops in the Civil War. He'd been a war correspondent in Russia when the Russians fought the Ottomans in the 1870s. He was brilliant at sort of sketching those beautiful sketches of public buildings in Boston. And he is the head of the American Academy in Rome, this guy Francis Millet. And he lives with a man in Washington, a much younger man. Archie Butt. Archie Butt, exactly, who is the military advisor to President Taft.
年度减肥冠军。年度减肥冠军，对。他们的家里住满了菲律宾男孩，这让一些听众可能会挑起眉毛。阿奇·巴特也是一个非常快乐且令人印象深刻的人。他曾在美西战争中服役，他使自己成为西奥多·罗斯福及其继任者威廉·霍华德·塔夫脱不可或缺的人。理查德·达文波特-海恩斯的书《泰坦尼克号人生》中有一段可爱的描述，他说为什么塔夫脱喜欢阿奇·巴特在身边，他说巴特会故意打坏球来激励那位痴迷高尔夫的总统，当他沮丧时，他会熬夜陪他打桥牌，
Slimmer of the year. Slimmer of the year, right. And their household is full of Filipino boys, which kind of gives a, you know, might have some listeners raising their eyebrows. Archie Butt is also a sort of quite a jolly and an impressive kind of person. He had served in the Spanish-American War, and he made himself indispensable to Theodore Roosevelt and then to his successor, William Howard Taft. And there's a lovely description in Richard Davenport Hines's book Titanic Lives he says why Taft liked Archie Butt around him and he says Butt misplayed shots to revive the golf mad president when he was disheartened sat up late playing bridge with
嘲笑他枯燥的法律笑话，减轻他在那位肥胖总统喜欢的可怕饭菜时的无聊感。这些饭菜，是的，早餐吃烤鸡、玉米粥和甜瓜，午餐吃鱼杂烩、芥末腌菜、烤豆和黑面包。好吃。然后当人们喊“嘿，胖子”时，他会安抚总统。他听起来是个很棒的人，不是吗？是的。他听起来很有趣。是的。而且最终，因为他淹死了，我的意思是，剧透预警。是的。塔夫脱非常崩溃，真的崩溃了。塔夫脱绝对崩溃了。是的。
him laughed at his dull legal jokes mitigated his boredom at the horrible meals which the obese president liked and these meals yeah broiled chicken hominy and melon for breakfast fish chowder mustard pickles baked beans and brown bread for lunch yum and then he would mollify the president when people shouted hello fatia he's he sounds a wonderful man doesn't he yeah? Yeah. He sounds great fun. Yeah. And in due course, because he drowns, I mean, spoiler alert. Yeah. And Taft is devastated, really devastated. Taft is absolutely devastated. Yeah.
所以有这对伴侣。我认为很明显他们是一对。是的。弗朗西斯·米勒和阿奇·巴特。这很有趣。那么，多米尼克，有什么主要的内衣企业家吗？有的。有的，是的。
So there's this couple. It's pretty clear they were a couple, I think. Yeah. Francis Millay and Archie Butt. So that's kind of interesting. And then, Dominic, are there any kind of major underwear entrepreneurs? There are. There are, yes.
所以显然英国贵族在那里，汤姆，与大内衣产业结盟。嗯，实际上，这是大内衣产业，不是吗？确实是大内衣产业。是的，不仅仅是内衣。是性感的内衣。有一个人，名字非常响亮，叫科斯莫·达夫-戈登爵士。所以科斯莫·达夫-戈登爵士就像一个讽刺作品里的英国人。他打桥牌，他击剑，他在一次射击事故中失去了一只眼睛。
So obviously the British aristocracy is there in alliance, Tom, with big underwear. Well, it's actually, it's big lingerie, isn't it? It is big lingerie. Yeah, it's not just underwear. It's sexy lingerie. So there's a guy called, with the splendid name of Sir Cosmo Duff Gordon. So Sir Cosmo Duff Gordon is like a sort of Englishman from a parody. He plays bridge and he fences and he's lost an eye in a shooting accident.
他曾为英国击剑。是的。哦，是的，奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利，当然，前《历史的余味》嘉宾，也曾在最高水平上击剑，不是吗？但他没有像科斯莫爵士那样娶一位内衣先驱。但实际上，多米尼克，奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利和内衣之间有一种联系，因为他为PG·伍德豪斯小说中的罗德里克·斯波德爵士提供了原型，他可怕的秘密是他经营着
He'd fenced for England. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Oswald Mosley, of course, former Reston's History associate, also fenced at the highest level, didn't he? But he didn't marry a lingerie pioneer like sir cosmo did but actually i mean dominic there is a kind of link between um oswald mosley and lingerie because um he provides the model for sir roderick spode in the pg woodhouse novels and his terrible secret is that he runs
尤拉莉，不是吗？那是一家内衣公司。所以也许这是一种对科斯莫·达夫-戈登爵士的致敬，谁知道呢？是的，我没想到这一点，我没想到这一点，汤姆。因为科斯莫爵士娶了一个叫露西·华莱士的女人，她是世界上最伟大的蕾丝内衣企业家。是的，她是一位落魄的淑女，她出身高贵，但她失去了所有的钱。所以她开始经商，并取得了巨大的成功。是的。人们可能看不起她，因为她是做生意的。但她得到了公爵夫人的赞助。所以公爵夫人们开始购买她的紧身胸衣之类的东西，然后它就变得非常具有社会排他性。她，在这个世界里一切都是相互联系的
eulalie doesn't he which is um a lingerie company so maybe there was a kind of knowing a riff on sir cosmo duff gordon who knows yeah i hadn't thought of that i hadn't thought of that tom because sir cosmo had married this woman called lucy wallace who was the world's greatest entrepreneur of sort of lacy underwear yeah so she was a distressed gentlewoman she was poshh, but she'd lost all her money. And so she goes into business and makes a tremendous success of it. Yeah. Yeah. And people sort of looked down on her, I suppose, because she was in trade. But she gets sponsored by duchesses. So duchesses start buying her corsets and things, and then it becomes very socially exclusive. And she had, everything connects in this world
百万富翁的世界，因为她去过纽约，在纽约开店时住在华尔道夫酒店。所以她，你知道，是这些伟大的先驱之一，在伦敦和纽约都有店。这不像维多利亚的秘密之类的。这是正如你所说，被公爵夫人之类的人购买的东西。里格比和佩拉，我相信。对。里格比和佩拉正是那个比较，汤姆。
of the millionaires, because she had gone to New York and she had stayed at the Waldorf Astoria while she had been opening her shop in New York. So she is, you know, one of these great pioneers who has shops both in London and New York. This isn't like Victoria's Secrets or something. This is stuff that is being bought, as you say, by duchesses and whatnot. Rigby and Pella, I believe. Right. Rigby and Pella is exactly the comparison, Tom.
非常好。已故女王的紧身胸衣制造商。是的。非常好。所以紧身胸衣制造商会吸引我们的下一位头等舱乘客，我会说他是史上最伟大的报人，汤姆。是的，我不会否认，他是W.T.斯特德，他是维多利亚时代晚期伟大的民粹主义报纸编辑。他确实是那个
Very good. Corsetier to the late queen. Yeah. Very good. So Corsetiers would appeal to our next first class passenger, who I would say is the greatest newspaperman who's ever existed, Tom. Yeah, I would not disagree he is wt stead and he he is the great populist newspaper editor of the late victorian period he's the person who really
发明民粹主义报纸的人，我会这么说。W.T.斯特德，老听众会记得他是派遣戈登将军——《历史的余味》的终极朋友——前往喀土穆的幕后推手。你还记得吗，汤姆？我记得，是的。回到19世纪80年代？是的。正是W.T.斯特德后来对无畏舰之类的事情大惊小怪。
invents populist newspapers i would say so wt stead listeners are very long standing will remember that he is the man behind the sending of general Gordon, the ultimate friend of the rest of history, to Khartoum. Do you remember that, Tom? I do, yeah. Back in the 1880s? Yeah. It was W.T. Stead who then kicks up a huge fuss about dreadnoughts and all that stuff.
你知道，德国要超越英国。他最著名的事情当然是他买了一个妓女，一个年轻女孩，不是吗？是的，为了证明这有多容易。是的。是什么？《现代巴比伦的少女贡品》之类的？正是如此。
You know, the Germans going to overtake Britain. His most famous thing, of course, was when he bought a prostitute, a young girl, didn't he? Yeah, to demonstrate how easy it was. Yes. What is it? The maiden tribute of the modern Babylon or something? Exactly.
正是如此。他被起诉了。他成了英国工人阶级的巨大英雄，因为他被视为揭开了所谓的“白奴贸易”的沸腾内幕，汤姆。他是个十足的江湖骗子，不是吗？他是个煽动者。非常有趣。极其有趣。
Exactly. And he was prosecuted. And he became a huge hero to the sort of British working classes because he was seen as having sort of lifted the lid on the seething underbelly, Tom, of the white slave trade, as it was called. And he's a complete mountebank, isn't he? He's a sensationalist. Very entertaining. Brilliantly entertaining.
我想他在船上会是一个非常有趣的伙伴。我想是的，是的。我能告诉你一个关于他的有趣事实吗？我的意思是，他确实死在了船上。是的。他也是一位坚定的唯灵论者。我的意思是，他确实死在了船上。是的。他是一位坚定的唯灵论者。所以他沉迷于那种东西。他在伦敦的家在史密斯广场，就在议会大厦旁边。他的女儿埃斯特尔在他淹死前和他住在一起。
And I imagine would have been a tremendously entertaining company on the ship. I imagine so, yeah. Can I tell you an interesting fact about his, I mean, he does die on the ship. Yeah. He's a committed spiritualist as well mean, he does die on the ship. Yeah. He's a committed spiritualist as well. So he's into all that kind of stuff. And his house in London is in Smith Square, just down from the House of Parliament. And his daughter, Estelle, lived with him there before he drowned.
在他离开前的一个晚上，她正在卧室里，这时一个男人走进她的房间，摘下帽子，坐在书桌前开始写诗。天哪，这太不寻常了。所以她走过去看了一眼，说你在做什么？他什么也没说，但她能看出那是诗。他完全无视她。是的，然后他消失了。第二天晚上，第三天晚上，第四天晚上，同样的事情又发生了。所以她告诉了她的父亲，她的父亲得出了显而易见的结论，这个家伙显然是个鬼魂。他有一套叫“灵魂指示器”的装备。那是真的吗？
And before he left, one evening, she's in her bedroom bedroom when a man walks in to her room takes off his hat sits down at the desk and starts writing poetry oh my word it's unusual so she goes over and has a look and says what are you doing he doesn't say anything but she can see that it's poetry he just completely ignores her yeah and then he vanishes and then the same thing happens the night after and the night after and the night after that. So she mentions it to her father and her father draws the obvious conclusion that this guy is clearly a ghost. And he has a bit of kit called a spirit indicator. Is that real?
那管用吗？所以它是一种与死者交流的装置。对。所以它是一种与死者交流的装置。所以埃斯特尔使用了它。结果发现这个一直进来的家伙是个诗人，他叫戈登·奈特。他专门写欢快的航海歌曲。现在他们建立了联系，他和埃斯特尔相处得非常好。你知道，他们度过了一段非常美好的时光。当斯特德在泰坦尼克号上去世时，这非常感人，因为戈登·奈特，这位小诗人，能够与她在阴间的父亲取得联系并传递信息，这样他们就能保持联系。哦，那很不错，不是吗？
Does that work? So it's a device for communicating with the dead. Right. So it's a device for communicating with the dead. And so Estelle uses it. And it turns out that this guy who's been coming in is a poet and he's called Gordon Knight. And he had specialised in rollicking songs of the sea. And now that they've made contact, he and Estelle get on really, really well. You know, they have an absolutely brilliant time. And when Wednesday dies on the Titanic, it's very touching because Gordon Knight, this minor poet, is able to make contact with her father in the afterworld and pass on messages so they can stay in touch. Oh, that's nice, isn't it?
是的。那是一个可爱的细节。是的。所以，我的意思是，显然这个故事里有很多悲剧。是的。但知道鬼魂……鬼魂的行为很棒。是的。所以，我的意思是，显然这个故事里有很多悲剧，但知道鬼魂……鬼魂的行为很棒。是的。这可能与他是一位小诗人有关。
Yeah. That's a lovely detail. Yeah. So, I mean, obviously there's a lot of tragedy in this story. Yeah. But it's nice to know that ghosts... Great behavior from ghosts. Yeah. So, I mean, obviously there's a lot of tragedy in this story, but it's nice to know that ghosts... Great behavior from ghosts. Yeah. Which may be to do with the fact that he's a minor poet.
你这么认为吗？如果他是一位更成功的诗人，他会有其他事情要考虑。我认为总的来说，如果你遇到一个小诗人的鬼魂，他可能会没事的。是的。一个体面、安静、内向的人。是的。没有被世俗的成功所诱惑，因为他们一生中没有取得太大的成功。不，他们只是一个小诗人。不，虽然整个走进女孩卧室的行为，我的意思是，这有点奇怪，但如果那个从阴间与你交流的人是T.S.艾略特或什么人，你会很失望的，不是吗？我的意思是
Do you think so? If he'd been a more successful poet, he'd be ahead of other things on his mind. I think by and large, if you meet the ghost of a minor poet, he's probably going to be all right. Yeah. Kind of a decent, quiet, retiring kind of person. Yeah. Not seduced by worldly success because they haven't had much success in their life no they're only a minor poet no although possibly the whole walking into you know a girl's bedroom yeah is i mean it's a bit odd but you'd be gutted if the person who communicated you from the afterlife was t.s elliott or somebody wouldn't you i mean
一个冷漠、严厉、难以相处的人。哦，我个人觉得我挺喜欢的。你会喜欢的，是的，我想是的。好的。是的。好吧，带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，我想我们应该快速休息一下，然后回来继续谈论头等舱乘客。
a sort of chilly austere difficult person oh i think personally i quite like to you'd like it yeah i think so. Okay. Yeah. Well, on that bombshell, Tom, I think we should take a very quick break and then we'll come back and we'll continue talking about first-class passengers.
可能不会谈太多关于鬼魂和诗人的事。我们也会转向二等舱乘客。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
Probably not so much about ghosts and poets. And we'll also move on to the second-class passengers. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在谈论泰坦尼克号上的乘客。汤姆，关于这么多头等舱乘客，有一件事让我印象深刻，那就是它通常被视为，你知道，你一边是头等舱，全是百万富翁。是的。波士顿婆罗门和镀金时代的美国财阀。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about the passengers on the Titanic. Tom, one of the things that strikes me about so many of these first-class passengers is that it's often seen as, you know, you've got first-class on one side, all millionaires. Yeah. Kind of Boston Brahmins and Gilded Age American plutocrats.
是的。而另一方面，你有所有的移民。但实际上，这些百万富翁中有很大一部分人本身就是移民的儿子或女儿之类的，不是吗？我正在看理查德·达文波特-海恩斯在他的书中列出的名字。亨利·斯滕格尔、约翰·鲍曼、雅各布·伯恩鲍姆、威廉·格林菲尔德、塞缪尔·戈尔登伯格、阿道夫·萨尔费尔德、亚伯拉罕·林肯·萨洛蒙、马丁·罗斯柴尔德、乔治·罗森沙因。头等舱里的这些人中有相当多实际上是第一代、第二代、第三代。
Yeah. And on the other side, you have all the immigrants. But actually, a huge proportion of these millionaires are themselves the sons or daughters or whatever of immigrants, aren't they? I was looking at the list of names that Richard Davenport Hines gives in his book. Henry Stengel, John Baumann, Jacob Birnbaum, William Greenfield, Samuel Goldenberg, Adolf Saalfeld, Abraham Lincoln Salomon, Martin Rothschild, George Rosenschein. An awful lot of these people in first class are actually first, second, third generations
是的。另一方面，还有所有的移民。但实际上，这些百万富翁中有很大一部分本身就是移民的子女或后代，不是吗？我查看了理查德·达文波特·海恩斯在他的书中列出的名字。亨利·斯滕格尔、约翰·鲍曼、雅各布·伯恩鲍姆、威廉·格林菲尔德、塞缪尔·戈尔登贝格、阿道夫·萨尔费尔德、亚伯拉罕·林肯·萨洛蒙、马丁·罗斯柴尔德、乔治·罗森沙因。头等舱里的这些人中有很大一部分实际上是第一代、第二代或第三代移民。
who are Jewish German-Americans, aren't they? It's really remarkable how many of such people there are. That is the melting pot of Gilded Age America, right? Yeah. Well, that's a lovely profound insight there. That had left you completely kind of...
他们是犹太裔德裔美国人，对吧？这样的人数之多真是令人惊叹。这就是镀金时代美国的熔炉，对吧？是的。嗯，那是一个非常深刻的见解。这让你完全……
I wasn't expecting that. It's your period, Dominic. Well, Richard M. Boyne says, he says, first class was only steerage twice removed. Very good. Which is true.
我没想到会这样。这是你的时代，多米尼克。嗯，理查德·M·博因说，他说，头等舱只是比统舱高两个档次而已。说得好。这确实是真的。
Well, because we talked about this in connection with Andrew Carnegie. Yeah, we did. Who, of course, doesn't drown on the titanic but is going out and then going backwards and forwards logan roy type figure very logan roy so what's it like being a first class passenger the guy we're talking about before frank millay he wrote about this he said of titanic she has everything but taxi cabs and theaters table dote restaurant a la carte gymnasium turkish bath squash court palm garden smoking rooms for ladies and gents
嗯，因为我们之前在谈论安德鲁·卡内基时提到过这一点。是的，我们提到了。他当然没有在泰坦尼克号上淹死，而是下船后又来来回回，就像洛根·罗伊那样的人物，非常像洛根·罗伊。那么，作为一名头等舱乘客是什么感觉呢？我们之前提到的那个人，弗兰克·米莱，他写道，泰坦尼克号拥有一切，除了出租车和剧院。有餐桌服务、点菜餐厅、健身房、土耳其浴室、壁球场、棕榈园、男女吸烟室。
and that's just some of the public rooms they had riding machines in the gym wow a riding machine they should bring those back i'd love that yeah i know i mean not that i go to the gym but i mean i'd like the thoughts of other people going on them. Apparently very good for the thighs. Yeah, I'm sure that's true. So they have dining saloons. They have lounges. They have cafes. There are quarters for the first class dogs. Yes.
那还只是公共房间的一部分，健身房里还有骑马机。哇，骑马机，他们应该把这些东西带回来，我会很喜欢的。是的，我知道，我的意思是，并不是说我会去健身房，但我想象别人在上面锻炼的样子。据说对大腿非常好。是的，我相信是真的。所以他们有餐厅、休息室、咖啡馆。还有头等舱狗狗的住处。是的。
Sun Yat Sen and Lady. Yeah. They have the first swimming pool on a ship. They have an operating theater in the sick bay. And the private rooms are very, very fancy. So Millais again, as for the rooms, they're larger than the ordinary hotel room, much more luxurious with wooden bedsteads, dressing tables, hot and cold water, electric fans, electric heater. The suites with their damask hangings and mahogany oak furniture are really
孙中山和夫人。是的。他们有船上第一个游泳池。医务室里有手术室。私人房间也非常非常豪华。所以还是米莱，至于房间，它们比普通的酒店房间更大，更豪华，有木制床架、梳妆台、冷热水、电风扇、电暖器。那些带有锦缎挂饰和红木橡木家具的套房真的
very sumptuous. And they're done in a great sort of medley of architectural styles. Some of them are kind of Regency Queen Anne. Some of them kind of Louis Caz, Louis Cez, Tudor, Georgian. You know, you choose what kind of style you like. But having said that, Dominic, there is a kind of integrity to the design because the white star logo is everywhere, isn't it? So all the cro it yeah so all the crockery all the plates and everything they're all stamped with the white star logo all the cutlery
非常奢华。而且它们采用了各种建筑风格的混合。有些是摄政风格或安妮女王风格。有些是路易十四、路易十五、都铎或乔治亚风格。你知道，你可以选择你喜欢的风格。但话虽如此，多米尼克，这种设计有一种完整性，因为白星航运的标志随处可见，不是吗？所以所有的陶器、盘子和所有东西，它们都印有白星标志，所有的餐具
everything it's the comparison that you made before with the world of historia yeah it's exactly the right comparison i think i mean for these guys it's not an immigrant ship it's a floating hotel they go to the gym. They go to the steam bath. They play poker all the time. I mean, the food, they obviously spend an enormous amount of time in this big Jacobean dining room. And the list of food is kind of mind-boggling. Yeah, it's amazing, isn't it?
所有东西，这和你之前做的与历史世界（Historia）的比较一样。是的，我认为这是完全正确的比较。我的意思是，对这些人来说，这不是一艘移民船，而是一家浮动酒店。他们去健身房。他们去蒸汽浴室。他们一直在打扑克。我的意思是，食物，他们显然在那个巨大的詹姆斯一世风格的餐厅里花了很多时间。食物清单简直令人难以置信。是的，太棒了，不是吗？
Oysters, salmon, lamb, roast duck, beef. And this, of course, is maybe there'll be people who've done cruises and things to sell this is you know that's nothing on the cruise we had much better than that but this is you know more than 100 years ago when refrigeration techniques and all these kinds of things are in their infancy and it's a tremendous enterprise to get all this stuff ready to have the huge armies of cooks and chefs and whatnot but i I think for two other people who are traveling first class, Ismay and Andrews, who are responsible for the design, for the conception of the Titanic, for the attention to detail, looking around and seeing how everything is perfect. I mean, that's why they're going there. So when Ismay went previously, he went on the
牡蛎、鲑鱼、羊肉、烤鸭、牛肉。当然，也许会有做过游轮旅行的人说，这没什么，我们坐的游轮比这好多了，但这可是100多年前，当时冷藏技术和所有这些东西还处于起步阶段，准备好所有这些东西，拥有庞大的厨师团队等等，是一项巨大的工程。但我认为对于另外两位乘坐头等舱的人，伊斯梅和安德鲁斯来说，他们负责泰坦尼克号的设计、构思和对细节的关注，环顾四周，看到一切都如此完美。我的意思是，这就是他们去那里的原因。所以当伊斯梅之前去的时候，他乘坐的是
Olympic and he was checking to make sure things that could be improved. And these improvements are now manifest on the Titanic. Yeah. They've got the right fish knives or whatever, the things that were missing, potato peelers. Everything is just so, just so. Yes, exactly. And obviously, that is something that they are incredibly proud of and that people are responding to. So whether it's the millionaires or whether it's the guy that we began with writing back and saying, it's amazing. Everybody is saying this is incredible. Yeah. And interestingly, the millionaires say it's incredible. So Colonel Archibald Gracie IV, he says, it's like a summer palace on the seashore surrounded with every comfort.
奥林匹克号，他当时在检查以确保可以改进的地方。而这些改进现在在泰坦尼克号上体现出来了。是的。他们有合适的鱼刀之类的东西，那些曾经缺失的东西，比如削皮器。一切都恰到好处，非常完美。是的，完全正确。显然，这是他们引以为豪的事情，也是人们所回应的事情。所以无论是百万富翁，还是我们开头提到的那个写信回来的人，都说这太棒了。每个人都说这令人难以置信。是的。有趣的是，百万富翁们也说这令人难以置信。所以阿奇博尔德·格雷西四世上校说，这就像海滨的夏宫，周围环绕着一切舒适设施。
There's nothing to indicate that we're on the stormy Atlantic Ocean. Lady Duff Gordon. So lingerie. Lingerie. I was entranced with the beauty of the liner. Fancy strawberries in April and in mid-ocean. Why you would think you were at the Ritz. You know, again, the comparison with the hotel.
没有任何迹象表明我们是在波涛汹涌的大西洋上。达夫·戈登夫人。还有内衣。内衣。我被这艘邮轮的美丽所吸引。四月份在海洋中央还能吃到精致的草莓。你会以为自己是在丽兹酒店。你知道，再次与酒店进行了比较。
Yeah. So that's first class. Now, the one thing that people probably will be thinking if they've seen the film is, this is all hermetically sealed off from the rest of the ship because there are barriers. And there are actually locked barriers, aren't there? Metal barriers between first class and second class. But the reason for that is not the snobbery of White Star.
是的。这就是头等舱。现在，如果人们看过电影，可能想到的第一件事就是，这与船上的其他部分是完全密封隔绝的，因为有障碍物。实际上有锁着的障碍物，不是吗？头等舱和二等舱之间有金属障碍物。但其原因并不是白星航运的势利。
It is demanded by U.S US immigration authorities, isn't it? It is. US immigration demands that there must be barriers on the ship because they are terrified of contagious diseases. Right. And they want to limit the spread of disease. And so people have had to be checked before they board the ship. Yeah.
这是美国移民当局要求的，不是吗？是的。美国移民局要求船上必须有障碍物，因为他们害怕传染病。对。他们想限制疾病的传播。所以人们在登船前必须经过检查。是的。
And all that kind of thing. So that's an important point because I think that's often seen as this is the snobbery of the millionaires or the snobbery of the company, but that's not right at all. It's the bureaucratic demands of the immigration service. So second class, it's a smaller group than first or third. And as you said, Tom, they are totally missing, aren't they, from the film? And I actually think from most popular accounts of the Titanic disaster, don't you? Yeah. Because as you said, the power of the Titanic is that it serves almost everybody as a metaphor. And so certainly for left-wing critiques of British American Atlantic society, the idea of haves and have-nots doesn't really have place for
诸如此类的事情。所以这是一个重要的点，因为我认为这通常被视为百万富翁的势利或公司的势利，但事实并非如此。这是移民局的官僚要求。所以二等舱，它是一个比头等舱或三等舱更小的群体。正如你所说的，汤姆，他们在电影中完全消失了，不是吗？我实际上认为在大多数关于泰坦尼克号灾难的流行叙述中也是如此，你不觉得吗？是的。因为正如你所说，泰坦尼克号的力量在于它几乎可以作为所有人的隐喻。因此，对于英美大西洋社会的左翼批评来说，贫富差距的概念并没有给
people who are in the middle. It's plutocrats or paupers, but that's not the case with this. Yeah. And of course, the nature of industrial society at the beginning of the 20th century is there are tens of millions of people who don't fit into those categories. And these are the people in second class. So they are clergymen, teachers, people who own shops, clerks. There are some chauffeurs. There are some up, there are kind of establishments now that are catering for the middle classes. And that's effectively the vibe that is being replicated on the Titanic. So Lions, what is it? Lions Corner Houses and things. Tea shops.
中间阶层留下位置。要么是财阀，要么是穷人，但事实并非如此。是的。当然，20世纪初工业社会的本质是，有数千万人不属于这些类别。这些人就是二等舱的乘客。他们是牧师、教师、店主、职员。还有一些司机。现在有一些机构是为中产阶级服务的。这实际上就是泰坦尼克号上所复制的氛围。比如莱昂斯（Lions），是什么来着？莱昂斯街角餐厅之类的。茶室。
Yeah. It's a respectable boarding house kind of atmosphere, isn't it? Don't you think? Yes. So films about the Second World War, the nippies, and civil servants will meet their wives when they're having domestic problems. Yeah. And they'll kind of hide behind menus and things like that. That's the kind of the mood that you're getting in the second class quarters. Yeah. It was the sort of a hotel that would feature in an Agatha Christie novel.
是的。这是一种体面的寄宿公寓氛围，不是吗？你不觉得吗？是的。所以关于二战的电影，那些女服务员和公务员会在遇到家庭问题时与妻子见面。是的。他们会躲在菜单后面之类的。这就是你在二等舱里感受到的那种情绪。是的。那是一种会出现在阿加莎·克里斯蒂小说里的酒店。
Exactly. You know, not super swanky. And the characters. So as you said, clergymen and doctors and so on. Yeah, absolutely. Interestingly, the single biggest group in the second class decks is Cornishmen. So there are several dozen Cornish miners who are going out to the Michigan Copper Belt. And they are very introverted, the Cornish miners. They don't really mix with other people.
完全正确。你知道，不是超级时髦。还有那些角色。正如你所说，牧师、医生等等。是的，绝对是。有趣的是，二等舱中最大的单一群体是康沃尔人。有几十名康沃尔矿工要去密歇根铜带。康沃尔矿工非常内向。他们并不真正与其他人交往。
There is a hotel in Southampton that caters specifically for Cornish voyagers. And there's one in New York, isn't there? There is indeed in Brooklyn, run by John and Sid Blake, the Star Hotel, if anybody's thinking of checking in. Anybody from, I don't know,
南安普敦有一家专门为康沃尔旅客服务的酒店。纽约也有一家，不是吗？确实有，在布鲁克林，由约翰和西德·布莱克经营，叫星级酒店，如果有人想入住的话。任何来自，我不知道，
Mullion or whatever, thinking of traveling to New York. But Second Class has really fun characters, I think. So there's a couple of people who've run off with their mistresses. There's a man, a confectioner called Henry Morley from Worcester. He has run off with a 19-year-old girl called Kate Phillips. So kind of middle-aged men running off with teenage girls. This is quite a theme, isn't it?
马利恩（Mullion）或什么地方，想去纽约的人。但我认为二等舱里有非常有趣的角色。有几个人是和情妇私奔的。有一个来自伍斯特的糖果商，名叫亨利·莫利。他和一个叫凯特·菲利普斯的19岁女孩私奔了。所以中年男人和十几岁女孩私奔，这真是一个常见的主题，不是吗？
Totally. And there's another one, a Lancashire carrot and potato salesman called harry form thorpe is running off with lizzie wilkinson well she's not a teenager she's 29 she's 11 years his junior but still what would the clergyman be making this well he'd very disproved of this man michelle navratil oh yes this is the guy who's kidnapped his children from his wife he's kidnapped his children so he he was from Slovakia originally, what became Slovakia. He had married an Italian woman and they lived in Nice. They had a very acrimonious divorce. He accused her of having run off with somebody else. He collects his boys and then runs
完全是。还有一个，兰开夏郡的胡萝卜和土豆推销员，名叫哈里·福姆索普，正和莉齐·威尔金森私奔。嗯，她不是十几岁，她29岁，比他小11岁，但仍然……牧师会怎么看这个？嗯，他会非常不赞成这个人。米歇尔·纳夫拉蒂尔，哦，是的，这就是那个从妻子那里绑架了孩子的人。他绑架了他的孩子，所以他最初来自斯洛伐克，后来变成了斯洛伐克。他娶了一位意大利女性，他们住在尼斯。他们离婚时非常激烈。他指责她和别人私奔了。他带走了他的儿子们，然后
off with them. He leaves a note for his wife that says, you will never see the children again, but never fear about them. They will be in good hands he buys second class titanic tickets and the boys and this bloke this bloke is by the way carrying a revolver they get on the ship so he's there with his boys do you know what tom this is a big spoiler he lives and you know what happened to him no i don't he became a french philosophy professor later later life. Did he? Yeah. And he lived until like the 1960s or 70s or something.
带着他们跑了。他给妻子留了一张字条，上面写着，你永远不会再见到孩子们了，但不用担心他们。他们会得到很好的照顾。他买了泰坦尼克号的二等舱船票，带着孩子们，而且这个家伙，顺便说一句，还带着一把左轮手枪，他们上了船。所以他和他的孩子们在一起。你知道吗，汤姆，这是一个大剧透，他活下来了，你知道他后来怎么样了吗？不，我不知道。他后来成了法国哲学教授。真的吗？是的。他一直活到20世纪60年代或70年代左右。
Goodness. I mean, who would have guessed? French philosophers do have kind of exciting personal lives. They do. Yeah, they definitely do. Foucault. And who was the guy who strangled his wife? Althusser, I think.
天哪。我的意思是，谁能猜到呢？法国哲学家确实有令人兴奋的私生活。他们确实有。是的，他们绝对有。福柯。还有那个勒死自己妻子的家伙是谁？阿尔都塞，我想。
Oh, really? I didn't know he strangled his wife. Yes. Anyway, could I just mention two travellers from outside Europe? Two. So one of them is the only black man travelling on the Titanic. And he is from Haiti. And he's a guy called Joseph Laroche. He's a very brilliant engineer. And he's gone to Paris, aged 15, to study engineering. He lived there. He's married a French woman. They have two
哦，真的吗？我不知道他勒死了他的妻子。是的。总之，我能提一下两位来自欧洲以外的旅客吗？两位。其中一位是泰坦尼克号上唯一的黑人。他来自海地。他叫约瑟夫·拉罗什。他是一位非常出色的工程师。他15岁时去巴黎学习工程学。他住在那里。他娶了一位法国女性。他们有两个
daughters who are aged three and two, but he suffers from discrimination in France and he's fed up with this. And he's had an offer from his uncle, who is president of Haiti, to go back and he can have a job as a maths teacher. Wow. Are they given out by the president, maths teaching jobs? Yes. So he's going back and they were going to go later in the year, but because his wife is pregnant and they want to get to Haiti before she is due to give birth to the baby, they decide that they'll go early, second class on the Titanic. And that's what they're doing. So they're on second class. And another guy from outside Europe is a Japanese, the only Japanese person who is, he's called Masabumi Hosono.
女儿，分别三岁和两岁，但他由于在法国遭受歧视，对此感到厌倦。他的叔叔，也就是海地总统，给了他一个回国的机会，他可以得到一份数学老师的工作。哇。总统还负责分配数学教学工作吗？是的。所以他要回去了，他们本打算今年晚些时候走，但因为他的妻子怀孕了，他们想在孩子出生前赶到海地，所以他们决定提前出发，乘坐泰坦尼克号的二等舱。这就是他们正在做的事情。所以他们在二等舱。另一位来自欧洲以外的人是一位日本人，他是唯一的日本人，名叫细野正文。
And he's a civil servant who's been in Russia. So he studied Russian in Tokyo. He's then gone to Russia to study the railway system there. And he is traveling back to Japan across the Atlantic over America. And then he'll go to Japan from the Pacific coast. So both of these men will feature in due course when we look at what happens yeah when the titanic hits the iceberg but i just wanted to flag them up i mean there's so many interesting characters in second class there's a guy who's a rubber merchant from liverpool
他是一位曾在俄罗斯工作的公务员。他在东京学习过俄语。后来他去了俄罗斯研究那里的铁路系统。他正穿过大西洋，经过美国回日本。然后他将从太平洋海岸前往日本。所以这两位男士在适当的时候，当我们回顾泰坦尼克号撞上冰山时会再次出现。是的，但我只是想提一下他们。我的意思是，二等舱里有太多有趣的角色了。有一个来自利物浦的橡胶商人
called joseph finney and he has a teenage companion with him, slightly dubiously. Richard Davenport describes him as a handsome bachelor with his gainy mead. Oh, right. More middle-aged men traveling with teenagers. Exactly. Exactly. He's traveling with a 16-year-old apprentice cooper called Alfred Gaskell. Right. Then there's a, this should appeal to you, Tom, a Mennonite missionary with the splendid name of Clemmer Funk. You wouldn't believe that if you read it in a novel. No. So Clemmer Funk, she's from Pennsylvania.
名叫约瑟夫·芬尼，他带着一个十几岁的同伴，有点可疑。理查德·达文波特形容他是一个带着他“盖尼米德”（美少年）的英俊单身汉。哦，对了。更多带着十几岁少年的中年男人。完全正确。他带着一个16岁的木桶匠学徒，名叫阿尔弗雷德·加斯克尔。对了。还有一个，这应该会吸引你，汤姆，一位门诺派传教士，名字非常响亮，叫克莱默·芬克。如果你在小说里读到这个名字，你都不会相信。不。所以克莱默·芬克，她来自宾夕法尼亚州。
Oh, it's a woman. Yeah. Yeah. Because they're not obvious with a name like that. I thought, imagine Clemmer Funk with a massive moustache. Right. Clemmer Funk could be the sheriff of some, I don't know. Hard boiled, hard drinking. But no, a M a mennonite missionary i imagine not hard drinking mennonite missionary who taught girls in
哦，是个女人。是的。是的。因为名字听起来不像。我当时想，想象一下留着大胡子的克莱默·芬克。对。克莱默·芬克可能是某个地方的警长，我不知道。硬汉，酗酒。但不是，一位门诺派传教士，我想象不是酗酒的门诺派传教士，她在
a one-room school out in india in madhya pradesh and she is traveling home to see her father who is ill and she's gone all the way from rural india she had to go to bombay then she went from bombay all the way to london i guess and then she has got on the titanic oh so she's been on quite a journey yeah she has so another possibly same-sex couple who claim to be mother and daughter but clearly aren't they are called lucy temple and imanita shelly lucy temple is from the bluegrass country of kentucky and uh richard devonport heise is very funny about them and he says an older woman from a milieu of stables and racetracks traveling with a younger woman from the drabbest of convict settlements should arouse mistrust one imagines lo Lutie Parrish with a rasping voice
印度中央邦的一间单室学校教女孩，她正乘船回家看望生病的父亲。她从印度农村一路走来，她不得不先去孟买，然后从孟买一路去伦敦，我想，然后她登上了泰坦尼克号。哦，所以她经历了一段漫长的旅程。是的，她确实经历了。所以还有另一对可能是同性伴侣的人，她们自称是母女，但显然不是。她们叫露西·坦普尔和伊曼妮塔·雪莱。露西·坦普尔来自肯塔基州的蓝草地区，理查德·达文波特·海斯对她们的描述非常有趣，他说，一个来自马厩和赛马场环境的老年女性，带着一个来自最沉闷的罪犯定居点的年轻女性，应该引起怀疑。人们想象着露西·帕里什那沙哑的声音
and skin like dirty leather and Imanita Shelley with a sharp pixie face and lashing tongue. Does he actually have any evidence for this? No, no. And then he says, there were surely paltry scams lurking in their history. It seems a bit harsh.
和像脏皮革一样的皮肤，以及伊曼妮塔·雪莱那尖尖的精灵脸和尖酸刻薄的舌头。他真的有证据吗？没有，没有。然后他说，她们的历史中肯定潜藏着卑劣的骗局。这听起来有点刻薄。
It's harsh, but it kind of makes sense, though. It's funny. It's insightful, Tom. That's the insides of a top historian. Yes, sharp pixie face and lashing tongue. Yeah. Okay. So actually, generally, we should say of the second-class passengers,
这很刻薄，但也有道理。这很有趣。这很有洞察力，汤姆。这就是顶级历史学家的洞察力。是的，尖尖的精灵脸和尖酸刻薄的舌头。是的。好吧。所以实际上，总的来说，我们应该说二等舱的乘客，
they love it, don't they? They think it's brilliant. Yeah. They're having an absolute whale of a time. Yeah. And the thing about the second class is second class on a titanic is as good as first class on any other ship you should be writing advertising copy for i should i love the titanic i think it should be pretty clear to the listeners now i'm very much on on white stars team and if
他们很喜欢，不是吗？他们觉得这太棒了。是的。他们玩得非常开心。是的。关于二等舱的事情是，泰坦尼克号的二等舱和任何其他船上的头等舱一样好。你应该去写广告文案。我应该去。我爱泰坦尼克号，我想现在听众应该很清楚了，我非常支持白星航运，如果
they're still around if they have a successor company and they're interested in sponsorship deals i'm there i'm absolutely they're all over it so they have a successor company and they're interested in sponsorship deals, I'm there. I'm absolutely there. We're all over it. So that is second class. It's absolutely wonderful. I think they get a very bad rap. Well, they don't get a rap at all, do they? The second class passengers.
他们还在，如果他们有后续公司并且对赞助交易感兴趣，我随时待命。我绝对……他们到处都是。所以如果他们有后续公司并且对赞助交易感兴趣，我随时待命。我绝对随时待命。我们全力支持。所以这就是二等舱。它绝对美妙。我认为他们受到了非常不公正的评价。嗯，他们根本没有受到评价，不是吗？二等舱的乘客。
No, I think White Star are getting a bad rap, Tom. I think people judge it harshly on the last day or the last few hours of the voyage. But the rest of it was brilliant. Exactly. Exactly. Yes. A lovely time apart from the last two hours right we should end with lawrence beasley they're sailing past the isle of wight and another guy called lawrence beasley he's a widower from second class he sits down to write a letter to
不，我认为白星航运受到了不公正的评价，汤姆。我认为人们在航行的最后一天或最后几个小时里严厉地评判它。但其余部分都很棒。完全正确。完全正确。是的。一段美好的时光，除了最后两个小时。好吧，我们应该以劳伦斯·比斯利结束。他们正航行经过怀特岛，另一个人叫劳伦斯·比斯利，他是二等舱的鳏夫，他坐下来写信给
his son to tell him what it's like and he says uh the ship is like a palace there's an uninterrupted deck run of 165 yards for exercise and a ripping swimming bath, gymnasium and squash racket court and a huge lounge and surrounding verandas. My cabin is ripping hot and cold water and a very comfy looking bed and plenty of room. I would like to see ripping. Yeah. Ripping come back as a word of praise. To be honest, that's why I liked that quotation. It was just for that.
他的儿子，告诉他这里是什么样子，他说，这艘船就像一座宫殿，有165码长的连续甲板供锻炼，还有一个超棒的游泳池、健身房、壁球场，以及一个巨大的休息室和周围的阳台。我的船舱非常棒，有冷热水，还有一张看起来很舒服的床和充足的空间。我想看到“超棒”（ripping）这个词。是的。让“超棒”作为一个赞美词回归吧。老实说，这就是我喜欢那段引用的原因。仅仅是为了那个词。
It's a ripping quotation. Thank you, for that. It's a ripping quotation. Ah, thank you, Tom. It's been a ripping voyage. It's been a ripping voyage so far. Let's hope it carries on. But the next episode, we will be looking at steerage. Third class. Which will be familiar to all viewers of the film as a place where there's endless Irish dancing.
这是一段超棒的引用。谢谢你，汤姆。这是一段超棒的引用。啊，谢谢你，汤姆。这是一次超棒的航行。到目前为止，这是一次超棒的航行。希望它能继续下去。但在下一集中，我们将看看统舱。三等舱。电影的所有观众都会熟悉它，那是一个有无尽爱尔兰舞蹈的地方。
People have a great time yeah and uptight millionaires daughters get to meet people who you know have won their place by playing cards but also excitingly tom we won't just be talking about third class we'll also be introducing not a friend of the rest is history, the iceberg, which will be striking at the end of the next episode, very excitingly. I mean, I just want to stand up for the iceberg community. I mean, the iceberg is doing what icebergs do, which is to float. And I don't want to be prejudiced against it. And if it hadn't been there, then we wouldn't be doing this episode. We wouldn't be doing the story. No, because we haven't done other transit landing voyages, have we?
人们玩得很开心，是的，而拘谨的百万富翁的女儿们有机会见到那些，你知道，通过打牌赢得位置的人。但同样令人兴奋的是，汤姆，我们不仅会谈论三等舱，我们还将介绍“历史的其余部分”的朋友，冰山，它将在下一集结束时撞击，非常令人兴奋。我的意思是，我只是想为冰山群体辩护。我的意思是，冰山只是在做冰山该做的事，那就是漂浮。我不想对它有偏见。如果它不在那里，那么我们就不会做这一集了。我们就不会讲这个故事了。不，因为我们没有做过其他过境航行，不是吗？
Except for Columbus, of course, and, and Ann Cortez. So if you would like to join our steerage community at the rest is history club. No, we think of,
除了哥伦布，当然，还有科尔特斯。所以如果你想加入我们在“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的统舱社区。不，我们认为
of everyone in a club as, as millionaires, don't we? We do. They're millionaires to us. Anyway, the rest is history.com. You get all kinds of benefits.
俱乐部里的每个人都是百万富翁，不是吗？我们是这样认为的。对我们来说他们就是百万富翁。总之，therestishistory.com。你可以获得各种福利。
Crucially, you get to hear the whole of this Titanic series right away. If not, you will have to wait till next time. So on that bombshell, thank you very much. We'll see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde.
关键是，你可以立即听到整个泰坦尼克号系列。如果没有，你将不得不等到下次。所以带着这个重磅消息，非常感谢。我们下次见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史的其余部分是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。